in the lobby of Ramsey solutions they're
here Kyle and Christina are with us hey
guys how are ya where do you guys live
we live in Portland Oregon awesome very
cool welcome to Nashville and here to do
your debt-free scream yes
fun how much have you paid off
sixty-eight thousand one hundred ninety
seven dollars boom look at you and how
long did that take seventeen months oh
wow
making what kind of money we started in
the low 90s up to around 120 and this
year will probably be close from 1:30
way to go what do y'all do um I work in
HR at core health and fitness uh-huh and
I'm a training coordinator and auditor
for a large aerospace manufacturer ah I
bet you are excellent very good
I wouldn't guess in Portland Oregon okay
very cool excellent yeah it's very cool
what kind of debt the 68000 a little bit
of everything
cars student loans a family debt a
couple small credit cards medical bills
from a born of our first first child you
were normal how long have you guys been
married five years Wow
so what happened 17 months ago that
started this March 2014 one of our dogs
got sick and after taking him to the vet
winded up with $1,200 worth of debt and
they really hurt us the following month
the engine seized on her car and it was
another hit so we had to take out a loan
because we didn't have any money so at
the end of that month our uh our the guy
that was we were in our house from sat
down with us and he was an investment
broker so I talked to us about money and
she made a comment that really struck a
chord with me was I just I wish we knew
more I wish we knew more of my money so
I sat down with our bank statements and
went through line item by line item and
we started writing down restaurants fast
food Dutch brothers Starbucks all that
consumable stuff yeah and it was 1095 19
in January in February is nine fifty
four fifty nine in two months we spent
over two thousand dollars eating out and
just stupid stuff
and at that point I went to work and one
of my buddies who I know who has done
this for a long time I knew he's doing
well asked him and he said download this
guy's book and listen to it
and from then it was off to the races
and I was five months pregnant ah okay
what's the first or the second or the
first the first wow that only that's the
wake-up call right there yeah that and
you look at the bill and it's just like
too much you know so you downloaded the
audio of Total Money Makeover yep and I
bought all your books since then and
Chris Hogan everybody well thank you
thank you very much we also went through
FPU was twice the first time was April
last year in 17 months you guys you'd I
mean you drink the kool-aid it was just
motivation cuz at first and the biggest
and one of the biggest pieces of advice
I can give to somebody starting this is
at first you're gonna be in saving
nickel mode you're gonna flip that
switch is like alright what can I cut
what can I get rid of the ESPN and all
the HBO and all that stuff get rid of
all that and then you need to flip that
switch over end to break it Aaron to
make a dollar mode so you need to be
saving the nickel you need we go out and
making a dollar doing whatever you can
I worked 2014 seven days a week 10 to 13
hours a day during the week in six to
eight hours on Saturday and Sunday Wow
just bustin it ot your over actually
double time no because I thought about
going out and get another job but you
make more work in me exactly my industry
they pretty much offer unlimited
overtime Wow
so I really took advantage of that and
one little side story that during this
whole thing is it was really tough for
me at first you know I was working about
four months just straight 80 to 90 hours
a week and I came home to tell her that
you know I I don't know if I could do
this anymore I I know where we're going
but I don't know if I can do it so I
opened the door to our house and she was
laying on the couch sleeping with our
newborn one month old son and I was like
you know what no I quit and telling
everybody draw that line in the sand
this is the reason I'm doing it I'm not
giving up I'm not giving in not now not
ever
there you go man that's strong that's
strong
so uh Christina that had to make you
feel strong oh yeah
brings tears yeah absolutely very cool
well folks you know you know those
listening in we get questions a lot
about debt consolidation and debt
management and all that kind of stuff
but what I hear in your voice is the
passion of sacrifice and the passion of
getting after and there's a pride that
comes with that as well what would you
tell folks you know about that sacrifice
and if there's other ways that people
think they can get out of this mess
how would you coach them towards the way
that you did it
I would I would the biggest thing
motivator for us was you got to get P
owed I know Dave you hear it every day
some of the people that call in their
laksa days achill about this they want
to tiptoe around the edges and the
biggest thing I can say is dive head in
you got to get mad and to get this stuff
out of your life otherwise it'll take so
long people get discouraged and they
think that they're not you know oh it's
not going to work for me and they end up
quitting but the biggest thing I can say
is just get mad yeah what's that what
was the decision to go back to Financial
Peace University again walk us through
that decision like what was can you
finished it and you were already on the
right path but you're like you know what
you're at the table and you say hey
should we do it again walk us through
that conversation I think we just found
a really strong community at our church
and all the people going there we're
going through the same thing and having
that common thing to just focus on every
single day makes a big difference you
know have a lot of people at work
supporting our family supports us but
they don't understand how truly hard it
is and the passion that you need to get
through it
telling somebody no you can't go get
coffee because you don't have the budget
for it takes a lot of strength as
ridiculous as that sounds but the people
FPU just understood and so it was a
really good support for us they're
inspiring positive peer pressure yeah
that's perfect
very cool other than the extreme work
that you did I mean you guys are busting
it yeah what was the hardest part other
than that oh my gosh for me I would say
probably living in a home that we don't
want to be in let me just say it's a
trailer park yeah we made you a trailer
park and she's embarrassed but it was
because the rent was less than half of
what we were paying yeah so we went from
1,400 down to 500 and there was a
sacrifice and way we moved in there and
she started looking around she goes we
make way too much money and we have way
too many teeth it's a sacrifice it's
it's just for a short period of time
yeah yeah and now you're done soon as
you get home yeah it's awesome
well congratulations you guys you really
have you paid a price on every front you
did everything that we would have told
you to do and really the intensity is
what caused it for you guys that's
amazing
very well done so after all of that
how does it feel Oh like you said
there's a pride you can't I mean we paid
it off in December and it was just like
a heap at first you didn't we don't
notice a difference but once those
January paychecks came and we didn't you
know work Bank and everything to buy our
house so instead of sending all that
money back out the door we get to keep
it you know inside of our household
until we decide what to spend it on yeah
I got a 30 grand and no payments and
only a 500 ollar rent right now I'm with
you very cool and what's your baby's
name Colby Colby and this is him
visiting as well you want to have in the
debt free screen you're the motivator
man
the reason this all happened be straight
I love
Kyle and Christina Portland Oregon
$68,000 paid off in 17 months counting
down
it scared the little guy in the quick
crying oh well then you know it's fun
memorable I'll tell you what that's a
beautiful picture he walks in the door
and he's laying there with a baby and
he's going I can do it yeah I can play
through that is so powerful and it's so
good you know folks who are listening in
on the video channel you could see the
intensity in his face because when
you've worked that hard and you've made
such good decisions and you see the end
of day that's pretty powerful now you're
making a hundred thirty you got no
payments
man that's serious Bank right there it's
good stuff hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show if you didn't know I
actually have my own YouTube channel so
I had to do videos twice a week on life
and money so you can click the subscribe
button to subscribe to my channel and if
you want to check out our video right
now check out the video on how to make a
budget